fifty-five seconds of logos the future
what x-men movie trying to erase the
past of every x-men movie after X two
would be complete without some Patrick
Stewart narration a dark desolate world
in fact this world essentially became
Tron x-men movie dips into the opening
DNA credits yet again so they wrote a
discount Human Torch
in the x-men that seems a little
shortcut issue oh when they found a
discount that robot thing from the first
Thor movie as well huzzah why doesn't
she shoot the portal to anywhere but
this facility this is so freakin cool
but let me ask you this how can you
throw something that opens a portal and
have it open a second portal wherever
you want without throwing something else
does she program it with her mind before
she throws it
I can't purple portal girls zap them 300
yards away before they take off running
most everyone in the x-men universe has
a power that is mental physical or
elemental this one opens portals it's
cool but don't get me wrong but this is
more sorcery than a DNA trait
why didn't she shoot the portals so that
the Sentinel would go to the next floor
or something and not five feet away her
power is walking through walls are we
just gonna give her mental time travel
abilities as well without any
explanation
you could build professor X a hover
chair to get down the stairs or you know
you could just make the stairs a ramp
the only way Marvel characters can be
revealed as defense contractors is via
magazine cover montages movies the
ability to transform herself into anyone
everyone knows who mystique is just say
your name already it was the first time
she killed him wasn't it last
thanks Wolverine in her DNA they
discovered the secrets to her powers of
transformation it gave them the key they
needed to create weapons that could
adapt to any Mutant power
how does figuring out the secrets of her
transformation allow anyone to figure
out all the powers in the mutant
universe and in less than 50 years the
machines that have destroyed so many of
our kind what created the hell took them
so long was it just the fact that they
needed to get to the era of the modern
x-men movies to make it work I bet it
was we can stop the Sentinels from ever
being gone and on this wall
for beginners hey magneto hasn't said
anything in a while let's just haven't
finished what Charles was saying wait
the Sentinels are about to attack just
as they're doing the time travel
ceremony I didn't have my powers in 1973
where'd they go
would that be important for me to know
before I go back in time maybe not where
do I find you oh it's complicated and
we're going to withhold that information
from the audience because the reveal is
sure to be amazing going back to the
1970s instant Lana lamps and Roberta
Flack Tunes to help remind you I'm ready
to take your blood mr. Jackman but I'm
having trouble finding a vein sorry I
couldn't do that one without laughing
well just to be fair for the ladies
scene does not contain an immortal
adamantium enhance lap dance he's hot is
we too late for that he already got
rocky and should buy the movie zone
rules already be hopping between past
and present Colonel Sanders
really is this an Adam Sandler movie
well we have orders this is a
quarantined area stand aside soldier
that's an order my men follow orders or
people die unless some other dude gives
them orders that are different than mine
you're killing me mystique had a chance
to kill Stryker and didn't do it do you
realize how much you could have spared
us if you just snapped this dude's neck
right now
damn it nobody who militaries for a
living notices this yeah there's no way
super connected secret military Stryker
guy I can't find out where that plane is
headed and have the mutants arrested
upon landing not at all and I'm gonna
say to you what you said to us then
cause actually he said go yourself but I
guess you can't expect this franchise to
keep track of itself especially since
this entire movie is just an excuse to
wipe out half the movies it's produced I
designed a serum to treat his spine you
know derived from the same formula that
helps me control my mutation seriously
the serum that helps you control your
mutation is in any way related to fixing
spines the fuck outta here he's just
lost too much so how the hell did he
ever get out of this funk in the
original timeline without Logan here to
break him out of it let's see a joint in
the ashtray multiple bottles of liquor
too many candles for a dude at a picture
of Jennifer Lawrence yep that's all the
vices
previously in a better x-men movie oh so
he's in an inescapable prison under the
Pentagon
why couldn't you dicks just say that
before also how do you get out of prison
before Logan went back in time he
obviously got out as we've seen in his
later Ian McKellen years was in there
when he forgot to mention yeah both
Charles and Eric forgot to mention a lot
of stuff before Logan went back in time
FK what else explains a bullet
miraculously curving through the air
har-har but honestly seriously also why
couldn't he control the bullet better in
the first place
this guy bends a bullet to hit mystique
without even seeing her later also how
did law enforcement even catch Eric in
the first place
this story is bollocks bollocks I tell
you be a young man grew up outside of DC
he could get into anywhere funny that
you would have never mentioned this dude
to present-day Xavier or recruited him
to the school or involved him in any
other missions just cooky just don't
know how they are gonna find him
we have a phone book because all young
men are in phone books and the guy
you're looking for totally lives in the
same surrounding zip codes to the
mansion I just don't understand the need
to transform right now why not stay
trashed the whole time unless her chance
of surprises that way
trash told the secretary that he just
came to get a couple files but she felt
this list of names was important enough
to run straight up to his office right
now because suspense we added some names
to the Paris meeting something we could
easily have called you about hours
before at your home since it's so damn
late the janitors are here cleaning up
but thanks to this awful timing now
mystique knows exactly where to go next
Maxon off I barely know it okay I'll go
die in a fire now Logan made a comment
earlier about having no idea where to
find Quicksilver but movie says uh that
they goes straight to his house you know
what thieving bastards like Quicksilver
like to do they steal Pepsi signs and
they're very loyal to one brand also
just because you use an arrow
appropriate Pepsi logo does not mean
you're still not selling your soul guy
is trying to sneak into a place start by
taking part in a standard public tour
gene where have I seen this before oh I
know every movie ever made
how did they figure out what time
magneto was getting fed every day I
realized you want to go to great lengths
to show this guard has all glass instead
of metal but Jesus does he have think
spare glass bullets on his belt for a
glass ass gun so these guys aren't the
same height this is probably shouldn't
work and if you're saying they are it's
a sin of convenience that he can fit the
same uniform and look I know there are
tons of guards everywhere and there's
probably a lot of new faces but there's
no one everything damn this kid is young
I've never seen him before well these
guys ever hang out after work at all
plastic or glass prison for magneto with
an elaborate entering the soul sequence
haven't I seen this movie before back
when was called x2 x-men United none of
the mechanisms that make this work
including electrical involve metal
apparently this escape plan brings the
threat of death by glass shards but one
is glass really you can't be killed by
clear things um the same 1970s gizmo
that controlled the security cameras can
also set off the sprinkler system
yeah no Dan even after all the time and
the alarms this poor bastard still taped
up in the elevator
and quicksilver's clothes are still here
they told me you control metal you know
my mom once knew a guy who could do that
yeah so I know Quicksilver is Magneto's
son and everything but the magneto we
know from x-men first class was a man
hell-bent on revenge consumed with
finding claw Smith want you to find time
to bank chips in America they told me
you control metal and wait a second did
this elevator run to the floor where he
was imprisoned because don't tell me you
can have a elevator like this without
metal because I'll punch you in the face
if you do wait is this movie actually
saying glass guns are a thing and in the
1970s movie asks you to consider whether
the world is moving in real time or the
music and quicksilver's 1970s iPod is
regardless the music and the action on
screen we see simply cannot coexist in
the same reality also am I the only one
who thinks this amazing scene would have
been that much more amazing if they'd
had the balls to run time in a bottle at
1/10 the speed
taking off 5 cents for the Quicksilver
because it's fucking incredible I'd take
off more if he was actually in the movie
more this article starts out talking
about the peace treaty in Paris but
switches gears to a story about murder
by the third column and repeats itself
in the fourth column also this article
about unemployment is actually a story
about a lost steamer imagine if they
were metal this is a pretty specific and
cheeky thing to have him say for a guy
who has no fucking clue what Loreen will
actually eventually get metal claws take
it slow and then Quicksilver went back
to his stupid basement teenage life and
did not continue to help the x-men or
feature in this story that's recent
what's the matter baby you don't think I
look pretty like this x-men franchise
continues to believe that men wouldn't
find mystique attractive like this it's
like putting glasses on Rachael Leigh
Cook or an antisocial attitude on Julia
Stiles I would paint myself blue tooth
mystique just once I'd like to see one
of these dudes not freak out call her
own or bull then get his ass kicked
anyway I didn't kill the president the
bullet curved
nope because I was trying to save him
again I have no clue how you were able
to see the bullet and if he could why
did you stop it so poorly you have way
better powers in that dude even if I
think it's nonsense that you had a
chance to stop it in the first place not
that anyone could have stopped them
anyway but where the hell is security
that can lock on to a marma half a mile
away and won't trigger unless it's
identified the target so in other words
the same bullshit long-distance DNA
reading technology shield built in
Captain America to striker who has his
gun out does not shoot this mutant chick
goodbye physics nice to know you
she's right at the last second these
assholes waited too long to crash this
meeting and they're just casually
walking in like the whole operation was
never in doubt Eric somehow guides a
bullet out a window and straight down
into Mystique's leg even though his
powers do nothing to help him see where
mystique is after she leaves his field
of view mystique chooses to change into
the black lady which good for her but
she's the only black person in this sea
of whiteness I was she not going to
stand out and then she walks by herself
through the robe area what's the
freaking point
Wolverine conveniently begins to slip in
and out of this time period so now we
can have an action sequence and let Eric
catch up to mystique I don't know you I
would either timelines version of
Wolverine not no beast or Xavier so he
jumps between the two times and also
loses memories from both times is he
waiting for all these cars get pulled by
Eric's magnetism but not the stoplights
street signs light poles news cameras
police officer metal accoutrements or
any other metal things just in time for
the big action scene to be over
excellent he would've come in pretty
handy during that fight - we have to get
out of here yes the front door is
definitely your best option terrible
Nixon look-alike is terrible
off the record damn it you just couldn't
resist making an easy Nixon recorded
everything joke could you movie features
enough pointless dog humor you'll swear
Michael Bay directed it from us defense
of these giant metal robots yeah because
you're in the Marvel Universe where
everything has to be giant metal robots
mystique is saddled with an extremely
chatty nurse who needs to come in on how
bad it must be to look like mystique why
didn't you find me he taught me well
Erik must have taught her when looking
for someone go to a random spot in a
busiest subway system and that person is
bound to show up also isn't Erik's face
everywhere on the news he's not even
attempting to hide or blend in oh yes
brilliant that mentioned that is in your
family history and surely in your name
excellent hiding spot movie keeps
fabricating obstacles so that this movie
can take longer I don't know not me but
I know someone else cliche Charles rips
off the Vulcan mind-meld memory by
touching things from Star Trek
unbreakable and underworld evolution
just because someone starves
skip you're afraid I'm sorry bro what
almost Oh hope isn't this the exact same
thing I have in Van code in an Iron Man
2 you know the controlling the robots
thing hey storm keep being awesome girl
I sure I'm glad they brought you back to
be a Nightwatch person ironic Star Trek
episode is ironic okay maybe he fooled
the metal scanner thing but still the
Pentagon has some pretty surveillance at
security I have no doubt that Erik knew
that his helmet was being kept at the
Pentagon but he knew the exact place
where his helmet was hidden oh look the
Sentinels of the future are about to
attack at the same climactic moment all
that 1970 ship is about to go down okay
we get it
we're in the freaking 70s where were the
mutant killing robots during the first
x-men movies remember what Charles said
and in less than 50 years it either took
them 50 years to perfect the robots or
the government had mutant killing robots
that we didn't see and no one feared or
talked about for years here's the part
where magneto lifts up an entire
baseball stadium and eventually drops it
down over the press conference as some
kind of a barrier despite the fact that
some x-men can fly or jump really behind
and more importantly that baseball
stadiums have several exits on multiple
levels which caused them to make for
poor containment barriers and I guess
they save money by shooting half the
b-roll in 8 millimeter and when you
watch this movie in the theater you're
like yeah Quicksilver but then when you
watch this movie a second time you're
like is this he stopped all 120,000
pieces of shrapnel from that explosion
except this one hey storm you know what
happens to a mutant who can control the
weather when she gets stabbed by a
sentinel the same thing that happens to
everything else yeah that Thor robot
definitely did this exact same thing I
wasn't all that impressed that
yes magneto tiny bits of metal shrapnel
are going to keep these all-powerful
beasts from getting to Charles in the
game you smart good in the future
do I make him yes but sadly you're
played by Kelsey Grammer so in a way no
do what you are made for okay so are
these things voice controlled now and if
a simple command tells them to track and
kill mutants wouldn't that put Eric in
danger super advanced mutant killing
robots are awful at aiming look decent
in theatres but now looks like some
funky ass CGI on repeat viewings cliche
one of them is in here
why didn't Trask mutant detector go off
when he was on the podium and mystique
was ten feet away you would think that
would build a presidential shelter with
concrete but no they use steel because
how else was magneto gonna advance the
plot you built these weapons to destroy
us why speech time by the way is this a
good time to mention that they've
already altered history so much that
their future self should be remembering
all this and that it's very likely that
they're not even at the abandoned temple
anymore
they'd probably be no movie either but
you know how we do Dan Colossus is only
in this movie to get killed my
futuristic sentinels oh look I was wrong
Quicksilver is in the movie again in a
completely pointless watching TV scene
awesome new movie someone gave this
creepy thing gamma wearing slimy toad
dude not only a job but a job working
the grill with actual food that people
are gonna eat and fear for too long
coolest panel in the movie is relegated
to voice-over and swelling music
montages because you know the past is
more important
geez finally where the hell is the real
Nixon then Charles finally gets his slow
the world down and do what you want
powers back right when it basically only
matters a little bit now shouldn't
Wolverine be dead by now how long can
that motherfucker drown before he dies
we know for a fact mystique drops the
gun but only then does the future change
but the future doesn't need to wait for
this does it it should have already
happened it's almost like the movie is
saying 1973 doesn't affect the future
until a major choice is made and the
1973 and 2020 whatever this year is are
happening concurrently of course there's
also the matter there being no movie if
they did this another way but you know
how we do Oh Q movie morning welcome oh
hey everything the previous movies no
longer matters anymore I'm sure all the
future x-men spin-offs and sequels will
be pure gold now that they've corrected
everything damn movie dwells on future
happy ending crap more than The Return
of the King what do you want us to do
with the major Stryker I don't know the
first thing I would do is see how his
lungs held that much water for a whole
day without him dying
I guess I'm gonna have to google this
when I get a chance
[Music]
whip lash
the only place I've seen dwarves and
dreams is in stupid movies like this Oh
make it weird put it to our finish
everyone will go whoa whoa whoa there
must be a fucking dwarf in it
[Music]
can you Hurley hate mutants doctor don't
you on the contrary I've a tender spot
my heart cripples bastards and broken
things
mark scotch scotch Mac nicknamed
shampoos glaze it do not take me for
some conjurer of cheap trick what he
wants to do with the major Stryker